[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
Griffin you know this is the new until
somebody can be and we have another
great episode that's some good p-funk
from Eli Windham and Rob kibble Kimmel
they got this great band there they're
up like Philly and they they sent me
that theme song really I've had a bunch
of theme songs I know you don't listen
to the podcast no no you ain't she sound
was on during it Wow
I got a true friend here with me today
everybody mr. Malcolm Barry yes I had
like 20 theme songs people made I put up
a little pole on one of my episodes on
YouTube and then like this is the one
than one but that was just the funkiest
one they made another one that was
pretty funky but that one is like truly
some p-funk stuff I look abroad how far
cuz I've seen you when it was just you
inside of a hotel room or something like
that making beats like Kanye at 17 my
little Casio yeah and then you know the
cartoons came and the branding like
people just jumped on right you know
what I mean I couldn't believe it
well here I am I know and I've been
asking you to do but I just wanted it to
be more in
someone of your stature I wanted it oh
I'm very popular at church Church famous
so Malcolm and I are part of a crew we
called the worst crew ever worst we are
the worst it's me
Malcolm Craig Robinson and Leonard
Robinson we treated y'all most of you
treat him like that mostly me you know
how baby we like put some respect on my
name right now make sure y'all put no
respect don't believe anything he's just
as bad but he's like one of those like
what that's what I went to how many
improv shows of his you right Leonard is
doing great at um where's he at
I went there once groundling Groundlings
he's doing great at the ground there's
so many improv you know to me there's a
lot of improv just skip but it's
actually sketch sketches not all wrong
we were we were in a sketch group when
you were coming up so I was in this uh I
did a handful what I would do is I would
stick around long enough to learn how
people did say oh you won't because I
didn't cuz I didn't like I didn't like
being a part of anything I didn't like
being a part of groups uh-huh you know I
like to leave you know I didn't go to
college full-on I kept coming back
leaving blah blah so I was part of a
sketch group called broken lizards for
like a hot minute which was like a cool
little group but like I wasn't like
really a part of it but I did a little
stand up and then back when I got to LA
I used to do two two to seven show
uh-huh Robin thede amber Ruffin was in
and a couple really awesome folks and so
I joined that just because I wanted to
see how to do long form improv because
they would do it with like commercial
breaks no I think yeah and raised this
like amazing so like I did that sort of
stuff but I never wanted to like stay
because I came from theatre I came from
do yes yes yes yes you were you know
it's funny I was in a schedule called
the suckling pigs nice it's always some
dumbass name and so why is what does it
was sketch name I know be stupid and the
thing to me that always would make
sketch groups fall apart is like lack of
leadership
yes like you need it one person to be in
charge but it's like all these eight
high personalities they don't want
anybody to be in charge yes even though
they want a network and directors and
producers to be in charge with it when
it's more official but it's like yeah I
feel like I feel like whoever's type-a
winds up running it yeah but like that
person isn't necessarily funny is there
just the one who most is okay with
setting up schedule right people don't
people don't yeah I know exactly so but
anyways you know back to Leonard is in
you know he's doing a lot of long
sketches and the way I met Leonard was
not Wilin out but it's less successful
offshoot short-circuits so I met him a
fee on Crockett yeah that's a kinder was
on very funny comical our buddy yeah
he's on insecure this year got a little
thing he did he was good on yeah I
really like that show I also did watch
that because I don't like to support any
equally so I want you out of thing
because I support all you want three you
you were on three shows that I watch
religiously can I tell you you are
actually a really supportive friend
thank you like that I can't even take
that away from Malcolm was on three
shows that I I still that I really enjoy
like it was like religiously what like I
watched it night of that's the kind of
thing wasn't like mazing so you was on
timeless yes okay you were timely he was
Rufus on timeless roof for some time a
preacher preacher
I love the preacher crazy show turned
into a vampire on preacher which I like
and I also liked Santa Clarita diet oh
my baby been on Santa Clarita diet told
him he looked good today he showed a
different shirt but he was he look good
on that so you were good on all those
things all scary characters to white
people you know a vampire a zombie
yeah I was really sad that timeless
didn't stay on I don't know what the
backstory isn't if you don't want to
talk about like totally cool how the
whole thing let's talk about it I loved
a timeless yeah and then but the only
thing that was like weird about it
because it was network television yes No
so then like you know you all in a time
machine and you going back to a time
whereby people were not welcome yes and
they they tried to deal with it's like
every person in the show was this close
to saying [ __ ] you know what I mean
like they say [ __ ] one time or so they
would use word it would be something
like that they know right I feel like
cuz we had you know we had a really good
writers groan very eclectic group
Blackman which is two more than most
rooms but they would try and I think
they were pushing I did really good jobs
and my boys LEM told me he was trying
who's like yeah then I tried to get you
Lynch talk to the network about that I
don't think it's gonna go but yeah but
that was a you know that was the funny
thing about doing the show is the very
first episode is have this big prison
monologue and fans of the show know I've
talked about on Twitter is that Eric
Kripke who's one of the creators of the
show him and Sean Ryan I'm Kripke who
now has the boys he's turning that comic
book into a great sort of graphic novel
um and I'm on an episode of two of that
oh sweet just working man I can't not
work my house go rob you it yeah I just
couldn't afford a gun but yeah he gave
me so much leeway because they had this
one sort of dramatic speech and his
words he was like sounds like we're
trying to win a gravitas award can you
just go do your thing
and I was like great so what's funny is
the show wound up being a family show
but to me in my head I never once
considered it to be a family show why is
that because in my head I'm getting
called [ __ ] all day
like in my head not even realizing from
the outside it's like no no this is that
cuz in my head I'm thinking about all
the ramifications in the world yes and
this and that so to me I was like oh
yeah yeah this is for adults and then
and then you watch an episode and I go
oh no this is a historical adventure
drama where yeah there's some butt
kicking and some romance sorta sort of
sort of a time-travel procedural yes
yeah they're like NCIS in time eh is
maybe would've stayed on the air DC's
who would have it no it would have been
like Law & Order yeah law and order like
time travel time travel unit yeah yeah
that'd still be on right now yeah so you
um okay so then you saw that it was like
a family show but did it what okay how
about this why do you want to know Erik
why do you think it didn't work
ratings weren't high enough yeah but it
did say no other reason than that no
because also it's so here's the thing
about it the ratings were high enough to
sustain how expensive the show there we
go
because doing a show like this it's like
you're doing a pilot each episode all
because do we never you same locations
we never use the same costumes so and
every story is kind of really epic so
it's hard to repeat that and so they the
fan love was undeniable and so they
couldn't you know you - yeah it was a
really it's honestly the craziest ride
of my career because you know we had
that first like we were waiting every
single time it was a weird wait like we
were waiting to see if it was gonna get
picked up in the first place and it did
and it was like wow huge so we did the
first season and it was clear that there
was a lot of love and then it was like
and then you know we got cancelled um
and it was like alright that's it great
that's cool I'm chillin
and then three days later on a Saturday
we get an email saying yo wouldn't want
cancelled well but then okay who did we
is that what the email said like you
guys are uncanny then it's like
another stab in the face cuz it wasn't
even like it still was canceled no no
this is what happened
they uncancelled it for season two yes
yes okay at the end of season one we got
canceled the show they kept going like
somebody got into a time machine that
was like please stop watching the show
give it one more time but please stop
and so like that's what wound up
happened we got uncancelled like three
days later and it was like okay they
were like this is not a joke this is
really happening on cancelled and so we
did season two and the thing about
season two was that it was gonna be so
we have less money but the stories in my
opinion were a lot stronger they were
more emotional and the idea behind
season two is that we were gonna be more
family related and so that was the idea
of the the stories but then what wound
up the we kind of got shot in the foot
is that then they aired I said like
10:00 p.m. or something like that so it
was like ready so it was like we could
have been shooting people in the head I
mean that was really hit but the hard
part about that is like you know with a
low-budget Time Machine show the heart
of it is supposed to be like you want to
see them going in time it'd be like
having a zombie show and you never
season yes well I mean the second season
we went back in time but there wasn't it
here's the thing if you watch the show
there's not most of the special effects
you wouldn't even notice a lot of the
effects because we know the only time
you ever see an effect on the show is
when the time machines go do you know
what I mean there's not a whole that's
when you notice yeah that's the ones you
notice the rest is like there's a
thousand people instead of 500 what was
the blimp one you know the yeah yeah
yeah didn't we built uh we built the
blimp I mean we built like when you're
looking up the blintze fake but then
when we're moving and all this yeah you
had a couple real fires I mean when you
see it from the outside exploding
obviously that's a real thing but we had
we built a lot of practical stuff for
for the Hindenburg and then the second
one was just sort of like the second
season was just relationship driven we
were in the month I mean that's where
they we changed it
being in the huge house that being in
the bunker yeah and I mean I went to
blow enough to like just these three or
four rooms which meant like less extras
you know and I mean sure that's how they
save money and those sorts of things so
then we got cancelled again and then the
people got pissed again and then we got
the movie the movie so the movie wraps
it all up a sort of yeah we kind of did
whatever I mean yeah I mean I'm that's a
hard it's a hard show to rap it's a
heart there's so much going on so many
subplots it's a very you know I commend
the writers on undoing this and and all
the effort that was put into it cuz it's
just a hard it's like alright so look
and listen in terms of all those
conspiracies and time-travel
consequences let's just wrapped it up
real quick yeah history save we out yeah
you know I mean I you know when you say
it like that as I look back on it I was
like yeah cuz you know they had this big
like evil empire and they tried to like
you know they had to wrap that up and
fix it yeah but you know it's how did
you feel being a part of like like the
network television shuffle down I'm like
what do you think about it now it's you
know for me that is probably one of the
most successful series I've been a part
of period so I'm thankful for every
moment no matter how many bumps there
were along the way because it's like my
longest running show before that was
better off Ted and that still was like
probably I don't know how many episodes
that even was might have been like we
had shortened seasons both seasons so
but I mean okay so I know what you say
in terms of professionally timeless like
kind of like people were like oh that's
to do from time that's to do from
talking anything like you gave you like
some notoriety and that kind of stuff
but what I'm just saying is like the
friendly black guy that yeah yeah I was
always a friendly black guy but this was
like like the thing is when you're a
black actor right black folks know who
you are because they're keeping track
you know other other black folks you
know other folks of color they keep
track you know what I mean but this was
the first show because I also had never
done anything this commercial before
right do you know what I mean I just I
just I try and be edgy in terms of my
career choices or make really
interesting choices something that
really I can dive into all
time so this was the first thing we're
just like this is my first family show
where is just like the whole family from
all walks of life sat there and watch
this show you know is very very
representative even on the show you know
we've got someone who's Lebanese Indiana
breast sure guy you know two three white
folks you know what I mean so it was it
was one you know the ratio was pretty
good in terms of like here's here's
white and then here's go with it you
know what I mean like it was a big deal
to me I didn't I never thought I never
thought me and Claude Claudia do MIT who
played my girlfriend Gia
yeah I never thought we would reach the
point that we oh yeah it was good though
and I never thought that because I very
rarely see black characters on a show
like this on a supporting drama really
have that relationship or really get a
relationship that can get shipped do you
know what I mean it's just like yeah
what do you mean by that
by that I mean where you watch two main
characters falling in love and as an
audience fan you watch and support and
want to see the ups and downs of that
relationship and that is a focal point a
focal point of the show now you've seen
black characters maybe here there where
they had a wife at home oh but this one
where you're like rooting for these love
interests where you're rooting for the
passions of the black guy to get with
this girl on this show where there's a
white lead and still have this
relationship be a front-runner was a big
deal you know what I mean to have one of
those cute little names of Rhea and
Orion thing yeah where people really
where where the relation my Jennifer but
yeah we're the relate with the
steadiness and the uncomfortability and
the success of that relationship was
plot driven it like what happened with
them was dependent on what happened with
the story would happen in the story
affected their relationship I had never
seen that so much so that when we had
rehearsal early on and Shawn was like
hey we want you two to like do whatever
I was like okay you know have over her
so I was like I don't know why rehearse
we got two lines again I'd never gonna
see this girl okay no you're doing this
and it turns out and in like four or
five
so didn't it's this whole lark of me and
her trying to reach each other through
time yeah yeah you know having a kiss
you know what I mean and I'd never
really seen that where like
our relationship was a plot point and so
that was a big deal and you know and
having someone who's Australian and
Lebanese and this black guy and yeah and
usually also you see black and black
where you see black and white so it was
fun to just see like a different
yeah we're shades of brown shades of
brown man there's so much you know what
I mean because I think we too easily
make it one of the other and it makes it
it makes the story stagnant mmm and it
makes it really boring and easy to me do
you know what I mean and so to have it
was just like a slightly different thing
where it's two nerds of color their
story matters - nerds - very smart yes
yeah - very smart
nerds where they're the it's not
ancillary our relationship was not
answered it was intrinsic to the story
and so that had a lot of value to me so
as you guys if you're listening right
now and you're watching and you're
hearing Malcolm you could see that he is
very artsy fartsy your life like you
know it's like I'm looking at you like
this [ __ ] over here because the
risk so what I was really getting at is
that you had this network television
family show but like you come from a
different background all together like
you're you're a theater guy like you you
want to be on Broadway you will you I've
been to one of your plays yeah you're
very likely your company is a theatre
coming he writes plays and then you
actually got a play going on right now
let's talk about that real fast real
quick I wanna get into the origin of
like you doing this yes so I have a
theatre company called amunition Theatre
Company and speaking of diversity a huge
thing about the company is that we're
diverse company in terms of having women
in power people of color and power and
not one of those token companies where
it's just like hey we've got one here's
our one guy you know but like we have
you know Asian Indian Mexican black who
are who I've been artistic directors who
have made decisions and so that to me is
an important part of inclusion and
having the stories told and so and that
theatre companies here in our life here
in LA ammunition theatre
and so the play that we're running right
now at the Pico Playhouse is a play
called brain problems that I wrote and
I'm the lead in leaders I'm out here man
but yeah it's a really fun it's based on
a buddy of mine who actually had brain
problems are true venous malformation um
so yeah and so basically the story it is
it's someone who's given
life-threatening diagnosis who copes by
retreating into his imagination which
was a hoity-toity way for me to just
write dancing Dixon to play drugs a
brain-dead yeah yeah that's that's
really it it's all an excuse to like
really just I mean the play is about
everything that goes through your head
in the course of talking to anybody over
five minutes you know how many times you
leave the conversation when you're
talking to somebody that's why crack
jokes every four seconds trying to wake
you up
teachers doing math and loud at second
parts but you take the derivative yeah
but yeah that's what came out good
friend time in here and so it was also
excused to use my entire theatre company
to use weird and so we're up now I've
never been asked to be in the theatre
company by the way but no but we're up
until May 19th we're open now and we're
until May 19th and we're doing good it's
fun people are saying positive things
you know get out there guys get out
there and see that all the links and
stuff will be on the description if
you're interested in going to see uh you
know maybe discount code Griffin yeah
so pay full price but you can see the
play just give us the money and we'll
give you a ticket stupid so you have you
started in did you start in theater like
were you from like what it is so like
this is like the dichotomy this is the
story a pitch when I'm talking about my
brand right which is that like I came
from bed-stuy fort greene-clinton hill
is Brooklyn right or it is you know yeah
yeah all all the places like you say the
places that white people who used to
drive through now they live yeah I grew
up in that Brooklyn it was this pre
gentrification yeah yeah I remember he's
gonna hate that I took this story I'm
gonna tell it we who are walking across
the street and where we going to a bus
and the bus stop and I thought we're
gonna cross the street and we didn't and
I'm like do you want to go to the bus
she like no [ __ ] over there do an idea
of where I live my mama yeah y'all were
bougie from beginning do it you know I
wish you were my mom my mamma's we out
here my mom my mom from the project's my
aunt from projects my mom less so my
living a projects now I lived literally
across the street from the projects oh
you thought you were better than
everybody
I wasn't isn't like a thought listen if
you had the border of anything yeah you
ain't in a good neighborhood you know
you're not you know you know you at the
border yeah you you didn't you'd live
farther away so then you wanted to
escape to her daily what's funny is like
I try to be uppity one time I was
walking through like almost gotcha
always gotcha I have gotten jumped but
this other time we're almost got jumped
I was welcomed by a group of dudes like
outside like the projects whatever with
this girl I was it you know I don't know
what it was but I was just talking [ __ ]
and I was like and I'm like I'm like a
got no jobs anyway maybe who's like what
I was like can't you see I'm just
fronting for this girl
[Laughter]
really bros before i'm trying to make
you look worse but me look better
yeah yeah I got jumped a bunch it once
or twice but you fought a lot I remember
my aunty my god yeah yeah yeah - a
couple fights I was doing alright but I
got jumped one time outside of a trade
station about like six or seven dudes or
something Pam and I remember you know
they took my bookbag my other bag
because I was playing football at a time
they took that and I remember when I go
to get a new book pack of my art he goes
well you better learn to fight cuz your
mom can't just be buying your new book
bags every week well he gots to learn to
fight cuz he gonna get jumped again yeah
do you see what we live yeah it's good
philosophy but yes so I actually grew up
a big math and science kid um so I knew
yeah yeah so I went to Stuyvesant but
then at the same time I was doing
theater and writing so for even in high
school even in high school yeah yeah
because I went to really so I went to
save so much had a lot of money and so
we'd put on these big productions and I
was like not a school spirit sort of a
kid right but around junior year I just
got heavy and then like I'm just gonna
act mm-hmm and was just in all the plays
and stuff and so I actually grew up
taking tests to get into the next place
so that was my life was a test taker and
so that's what got me into whatever
schools so by the time college came I
there's no particular test to tell you
what school to go to right I heard it
NYU and I'd been acting so I went to NYU
theater that was that was it yeah and
then I was just doing theater all
through that and doing television at the
same time and and a little bit of
theater went on tour and then finally I
got a gig the very first gig that's with
me to LA was Louis not the one you're
thinking of Luis Guzman yeah first gig
but I got to see a lot of penis
but but yeah that was the first gig I
got was was with Luis Guzman and um
Charlie Day was on there which is how I
know Charlie day which is why I ended up
on the pilot episode of sunny in
philadelphia
oh yeah yeah cuz we did a couple in
residual yeah so we did a couple
episodes of that it got canceled Charlie
asked me to do he said hey I have think
about this now as far as sunny in
philadelphia it's correct
he goes hey there's a show I got what a
couple buddies of mine were doing just
wants you to come in and sort of
improvise a thing that maybe cover on
the show so I actually wound up
improvising at Rob's house it was like
me him and like we we did that and I
know out of there like yeah you're just
gonna do the job and they they shot I
think they were shooting like three
episodes in a week or something like
they were they were they were doing at
least for the pilot of it they were
doing a bunch of episodes at the same
time total low-budget oh yeah watch
shooting yeah yeah they were just doing
like they were like yeah we got this
other they're like yeah we'll come back
to your scene we're doing the scene with
the twins or whatever the heck that is
and blow but I was like oh okay all
right great and it just wound up being
the pilot their pilot was gonna be the
cancer one Charlie has cancer and then
they did the one where the game gets
racing right like no this is even this
is this is where so much so many years
later so much money so many episodes and
all are huge and have their own thing
yeah and so you know very awesome for
them so you did that so that was like
that brought you to LA though that
brought me to that you never loved and
another than that I never left cuz I did
that I did the Louis show and I was like
it got cancelled and I said one let me
kick the ball and see where it goes
again and so honestly my career outside
of from jobs I actually got was was
booking pilots like I booked that's how
I got paid like I booked I've booked a
pilot every year since 2003 oh [ __ ] yeah
that's that is you gave one this year
too right our house our house with
Katherine Heigl yeah how did that go
great she's not a [ __ ] that's really I
feel like that's everyone's first
question we'll see what we learn not to
be here for why I don't know you know
it's funny I only work
I have no idea yeah I have no idea I
actually I actually read for that too
that's who as a husband yeah that's
crazy I know man when I saw that you got
that I was like okay good
yeah yeah because it was like I just
feel like they're secretly making all
white shows this year yeah well not well
CBS they they they they're on the
interracial couple things yeah yeah yeah
don't do a whole black family buddy yeah
I was pitching in the callin it's called
our house but I was pitching calling it
my white wife you gotta stand out y'all
yes oh you did you did the pilot and
everything it's like the pilot that the
pitching went great had a lot of fun
everybody in the cast is amazing
talented the writers were fun Nick
Stoller Brendan O'Brien
oh yeah Nick yeah Nick Stoller has a
little bit of a track record so you wait
and you did okay so was that it that was
a multicam write multicam 3 camera Wow
old-school Kathryn never been in front
of an audience before oh wow yeah yeah
click though man we were like there's a
lot of fun man they let me talk and
pitch and do all those sort of like you
know that's like tone but tone bells
been on the podcast too so he got his
interracial couple on the other network
yeah nothing was called my white wife on
the other in this game they want you to
know what life is like between a black
person funny though that it's like oh
like black man white listen it's a weird
it's it's such a weird if they ready for
the other way yeah white dude and black
I think they're gone we gonna say they
not ready for whatever they don't show
it this just you know I mean like should
me the fact that we even still talk
about it like that is proof that it's
there's still some things on stigma yeah
you know that's still happening which is
weird like that that's innovative and
it's funny to see no sale is oldest time
I know and it sucks that yeah it sucks
for black women they seem to be getting
it the worst in terms of light right yes
in terms of like who's getting more
speaking parts the
with get out is the is that Lapita who's
in get out yes that um it is it broke a
record because it is the first movie
starring a black woman ago number one oh
wow
I don't want to get that wrong no not
more than Whoopi I mean what movie will
be what number one Eddie what it oh I
love woof yeah me too
I have the utmost respect for Whoopi but
I can't think of another you know I
don't know but I thought like a show
like insecure on HBO there are buddies
amazing sorry I thought it was like such
an important show because like seed now
you let me ask you just to so we get
good into talking about this so you did
you have mother and father living with
you at home my mother my dad did at some
point but then he was gone
okay he went classic get a pack of
cigarettes okay but but did you okay so
when you were when you were coming up
growing up and dating in college did you
exclusively they black women but you
were very eclectic in your dating
choices United Nations over here uh I
mean I started look I'm from bed-stuy so
I started it was black and Puerto Rican
okay got you know what I mean I was
whatever my options were you know but I
thought black women in Puerto Rican were
like the most beautiful woman okay see
this is what I'm talking about
alright that's great to hear yeah
because what I'm saying is like where I
can't look I'm so mixed and like I grew
up like you know like a block away from
the hood no do you like you you you
throw me off because I'm not sure with
jokes to make all the time it's a it's
gonna be racist yeah exactly I always
say people want to know what you are so
they can know how to hate you so what
I'm saying is when I grew up and my mom
wanted me like away from the hood so she
like sent me to like white schools and
like I went you know so I had just like
like I and then like I feel like when we
were growing up black women on
television in me
yeah it was it was always negative it
was like if you saw a black woman on the
show she had to be sassy she had to be
said or she had to be fat had to be
loved being sassy yeah so right you know
what I mean yeah I mean who do we have
growing up I'm like trying to this is
what I'm trying to say so that's why I
feel like to show insecure is so
important because this is the first time
I've seen black women like be sexual
creatures this is the first time I've
seen multiple dark-skinned women on TV
oh that's true to that what you went
there with it because a lot of times
they'll they'll introduce like the new
thing they like when cuz you know
scripts will be like with scripts will
do is they won't say all white people to
just hire all white people yeah yeah
yeah and then the one character
description will say like sometimes
they'll give a person of color they'll
say it's a person of color or they'll
say this or that but then they just what
TV likes to do now is they like to do
like ambivalent color yeah so like
whatever you all races except yeah like
well the person will just be some color
where you're just like okay so I don't
know what they are so I guess I'm not
racist yet yeah wanna be I wanna be but
that's funny you say that because I
always find that I go in later in the
process so it's like they've made this
show they don't know who they want and
then you know but normally it's like
it's gonna be all white you know cuz
it's a white star his friend is white
you know that just said what happens and
isn't it and I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with them and just like
you're a world you know but then what
happens is later they start to look at
the cast to go oh this is we can't we
gotta like and then that's when they go
let's bring some ethnic people yes but
then it's weird
then it's weird because it's not made
for it we're going right for you they've
won their intention exactly so it looks
like crap which is why you know you got
the shows like ATL and insecure where
you're having black creatives right for
black actors and it's gelling so much
more because they're writing forth Rai
Rai Rai you feel like a fly on the wall
yeah you know what I mean like sterling
Kate Brown talks about that and doing
this is us and that he's like you know
when he won his award I think when he
got his first Emmy and he talked about
having this role written for me and I
remember a couple white actors writers
were like how do you feel about that
because a lot of them their tactic is to
or some
writers are like they felt like you
rights in general and then maybe we can
put a black guy or we put in there and
it's just like no you know what's super
rewarding is like you intended for this
to be a black yeah yeah like because our
lives aren't as interchangeable as you
think they are exactly it's just come
from different places perspective but it
in the same way that like all white
people aren't to say no and I just don't
understand why they don't apply it to
people of color
no because because you have to know the
breath of people of color you have to
know the breath of black people you know
like put it like this there's a there's
an episode of timeless in the pilot of
timeless there's a line that I say to
the Mason character played by the
amazing Paterson Joseph where I have a
line and I go um going back in the time
is not awesome for it you know there's
no time in American history that's gonna
be awesome for me
right and the writers are like it's not
quite hit and it's not and I was like I
got this then I go and I had alive like
I don't know how it works across the
pond but over here it's racist yeah and
so even understanding the fact that a
black British person had a totally
different comparing different experience
than an American black person is an
understanding that all people don't
necessarily know even understanding that
every black person is not African
American like that's like a big like I
get on Twitter and people are everyday
every once in a while I'll make that
reference and people get so confused and
they're like I just you know I don't
know what you're supposed to call people
and I'm like well you know it's
factually inaccurate to call a black
person not from America America like
African American like it's just
factually enacted just cut yeah yeah you
know because they'll look at a black
person they go because they're
uncomfortable saying black is
african-american still the thing right
now I don't hear it as often I I hear it
I hear I don't mean I don't know I hear
it literally like yeah because I think
professional settings yeah because I
think people are still I think white
Americans are still uncomfortable saying
black which is because they're it cuz
they're only they used to only say it in
whispers so it's like so to say black
feels weird so that
like okay proper thing is
african-american and it's just like I
get really trying to do but like he's
British
or he's Jamaican or he's like my mom my
mom's like this you might not to cut you
off from so sorry but no like I'm Lee
and all my mom's from Belize you know
it's like so anyway people from Belize
and Jamaica they actually have a big
problem there's a big rift between
people from those places and American
black people huh they're not they don't
have the same experience even though
these places were slave ports yeah yeah
so even though the like like Jamaica and
believes they were slave ports and then
they eventually got their independence
so then they had this kind of like you
know but they don't forget it all came
in the same play but I know what you're
saying it's like it's not the same it's
not the same and I think in order to
great for that you have to know about
that right oh yeah do you know who would
know about that where do you find out it
something something we talk about
industry yeah I tell you who's not
talking about it is 12 white men in the
room in a couple of white women yeah
they're not talking about like slave
ports do you know what I mean so I think
that's a whole thing like even teaching
that like yeah Africans who immigrate
over here don't call themselves African
America because they know what part of
Africa they're from right right a big
[ __ ] they're like I'm from I'm
Nigerian yeah I'm from Chad like that's
like saying like for them it's like
saying like Earth's America yeah exactly
we gotta say African America because we
got no records yeah that's so that's a
whole other conversation that like if
you're not ready to have that
conversation you're not ready to write a
30 second joke that's true you're not I
mean some joke in the middle of a show
and then fairness to these why people to
though it's like you know that they're
thrusted into a situation whether you
know we're like mandates are coming you
know so yeah we we got to get a couple
black people on this yeah yeah then
they're like
you know they're trying to like I think
anytime we're trying to skirt the line
they they err on the side of like
caution like yes but at the same time
Anila as possible yeah that's the thing
is just like ok we'll make it that but
that's the thing about having like power
at top right because if you had more
writers of color if you had more people
looking at content that has a little
more variety if you have more people of
color in in the room with more power
then more work gets created you know
what I mean that's who's creating ATL
and insecure and and all these other
things timeless is like they allow
people of color to be producers to be
right at as creators of their own
content as opposed to answering to
somebody else who's giving you notes on
your own culture yeah then it comes to a
thing where it always boils down to like
you know get selling ads and stuff like
this - yeah you know that cuz I kinda
noticed like an insecure the last season
it was only eight episodes
mm-hm and I was like wow this is only
eight episodes of this show and there's
like 25 episodes of some show on a
network that but who's watching it like
I don't know so I mean as much progress
has been made there's still a ways to go
yeah and you have to keep mindful of
that you know what I mean it's about
what your priorities are and if your
priorities aren't about like empowering
people then that's not what you're gonna
make a show about you know I mean if you
don't care you're not gonna do that you
know I mean I care so like I try and
like bring writers of color into
whatever I can and create a theater
company and do whatever the hell else
makes sense and like I'm trying to get
power yeah yeah yeah you know what I
mean like that's partially why I did our
house cuz like I'm higher up on the call
sheet
writing things and yeah yeah yeah you
gotta be you gotta be at least one or
two right you know to up in this [ __ ]
wow man you know I may not play - okay I
can't believe I got her on a comedy she
look the way she broke out was knocked
up oh that that's true yeah people
forget I mean I didn't see like oh no no
she was already on Grey's Anatomy well
yeah yeah I mean like the way movie was
movie
movie was because she had Grey's and I
think she was on Roswell to Shiraz I
think she's one of the chicks on what
are you watching right now uh are you
even watching TV you seem like one of
those bougie I don't watch TV oh that's
all I do is watch okay good good what do
you want tell me what you're watching
right uh what I'm watching right now
obviously Game of Thrones watching right
now what else uh little Adam ruins
everything
Legion into the badlands are you like
Legion I do you know what I was having
on first season it sees it not as much
now now I'm just like Netflix and
everything I totally with you on the
Legion thing yeah like first season I
was like I'm really into this it's out
there it's weird like what's really
happening like who's what who's what but
the second season they lost me yeah I
just was I checked out because there's
so many shelves to watch I can't you
know what this happened with Legion and
Westworld
I was I watched both of those first
season and in the second I was like I
just don't my brain space dude is in
there for how long between stuff happens
yeah well first of all Westbrook emo
Terminator like Terminator like I just I
just and I smoke a lot man I can't
remember everything like I'll remember
nobody's name on Game of Thrones and I'm
watching that like crazy I'll remember
my friend's name speaking of is like you
know I know you know you know me you
know be weirded out by this but I just
went to a weed store for the first time
okay I browsed and I got me so uh you
know a little CBD pin okay with like a
1:4 ratio you know and I'm like oh this
is I'm all about this now oh I just
bought weed I never I still don't know
how publicly how much publicly I'm
supposed to talk about that at all I'm
like very cuz I'm like very
I'm almost commercial so I got I never
yeah you and
would you think you've put yourself into
like you you have weird Lane yeah you're
like yeah you're like the star of a CBS
sitcom no idea I have no idea and plus
I'm waiting I'm waiting for like my old
tweets to be brought up or something I'm
always I'm always waiting for like yeah
like what my tweets were like when it
was like 30 people yeah well now you
just let everybody to like we gotta go
searches yeah
search it up yeah I pride myself on
believing that there is no tweet I've
put out there at that wall that I will
regret in the least I know I can't do
that I can't I know that there is for me
as a comic you know cuz like cuz it's
because the the sensibilities change in
society true this is true you know I
feel like it's I feel like it's I can't
tell if that's harder or easier for you
because you're also you're going out
there whereas I I lean into the comedic
parts of things but I still get hired by
Network right right right
you know what I mean so it's always this
weird balance where I'm just like and
plus it's like we've legal now but like
laws always take a little bit for black
people to make it legal like they need
to stop making it it's still a federal
crime is still a federal crime yeah
that's great it's absolutely crazy
yeah weird system yeah you know yeah
it's almost like you know like
somebody's saying to you you can't you
could you could do that over here yeah
yeah you know but Shh yeah
don't tell Dad yeah yes is it okay like
is it okay what was crazy they can't get
banks to it was crazy is I I get nervous
about talking about that but I bet if
I'm just like you know I was drunk the
other day with George Clooney like yeah
I mean it's weird yeah it's a wee it's a
weird it's a weird sort of stigma that I
know but I myself like it was great at
night I find like I said oh my this pin
is great just yeah I could click I turn
my brain I realized that my brain I
don't sleep good enough because my brain
is still going after a show that I'm
just sitting them with you whatever and
I'm like okay then it's like I've sleep
until whatever yeah that's that's kind
of my problem is like I my brain is
overly active well when I'm when
completely sober I am incredibly
neurotic like we're talking about we're
like when I don't drink I don't smoke or
whatever I just feel like I talk too
much I think too much there's just I'm
sure it's like a normal amount and I'm
and I'm a lot more productive like I
wrote the play when I was completely
sober oh wow
yeah I like was not he's drunk and look
at it like who the [ __ ] made the drink
one night
yeah cuz you know that you know what
happened is what happened I was coming I
was just started doing preacher the
first season a preacher just came off
timeless which was great preachers one
of those shows that nobody watches but
it's actually a great show so great I
mean this is my type of shell and are
you dead are you coming back at all do
you know well because I'm a vampire and
yeah you got burned buddy you didn't see
your death yeah I'm I'm gonna say I'm
dead you did yeah without you dead
because you're on another show yeah yeah
I'm not gonna let you you're not gonna
be number two on this show and then be
known oh well you know I was doing time
with some preacher I know I know but
they worked that out you will read out
the whole industry [ __ ] yeah that
was Sony I was I was Pippin for two
years yeah sure for you couldn't tell me
nothing on now don't tell me first I'm
thinking that good man and I'm repping
studios all of a sudden I'm like yo
shout-out to Sony yeah
bringing that hot fire so stupid
but yeah but like basically I'd like
gotten fat and I was just like I'm still
out of shape and so if you're out of
shape but you look good your body makes
scent like I'm skinny you know what yeah
you have the head of somebody that's
supposed to be 40 pounds I can't do that
I can't do that
and so yeah I like there was like a
three-month period where I wasn't
drinking I was smoking I was working out
doing oh good for you Muay Thai now I'm
more of a balance between all of that
but like I wasn't doing that and then my
friend he was going through the surgery
and I just wrote this play and I wrote
it quickly because I was completely
sober for one and so like it's amazing
how many hours in a day you know there's
24 and every doens crazy every day you
think it him early you ever get up like
you
like really early so you go to 6:00 a.m.
and you do all this [ __ ] you look at the
clock and it's like 11:30 and you're
like god damn I did a lot of [ __ ] before
her noon yeah I ruined my life but let
me ask you about the play yes now when
you sat down
did you write sat down with the
intention do you always go with the
intention of I need to make just a play
first you know what it was I had a
Writers Workshop group and so I was just
like I just wrote 10 pages just to show
the group look we need to write for each
other so I wrote that Tristan my boy
Bernardo was like who went on to direct
it was like you need to write this a
whole play oh wow so you just go play I
just go you never think in TV movie
that's not your I'm just interested to
hear like how you like I wanna make just
a play yeah you know I mean it's LA so
like a lot of my writing if I'm creating
anything I'm trying to think of where
that content goes I'm just not good at
creating like episodic TV shows like
interest my brain doesn't go there of
like what do I want to do every week
nothing there's nothing there's nothing
I want to do every week so I have movie
ideas and I've been right and over the
last two years or so I've pitched TV
shows you know really odd sort of TV
shows and so that's mainly what I try
and do if I'm gone on right but this
just made sense to be a play just
because how weird it was and the
surrealism and magical realism that was
happening but he challenged me too he
said now write the first act in a month
and I say okay and write the second you
need people like that in your yeah and I
also had to finish it before my boy
Tommy went in the hospital because I
didn't want real life to determine the
ending oh right on my place you were
like yeah you know but yeah so it just
that's just how it wound up happening
and you know agents the first thing I do
you know he's like do you think this is
this type of thing that good they want
to adapt what you're saying I do think
so
look if somebody say yeah and yeah but I
guess the more famous you get the more
kidding yeah your clothes cuz your cuz
when you look at someone like the danny
glover or what's the name down clever
Danny will come Danny Glover wrong name
either Donald childish gambino mean
which you also by the way wrap you off
so he's also a rapper has a group right
yeah yeah very valid Icarus verb yeah
there it is yeah so this is I'm talking
about actor writer director performer
yeah it's so like do you see when you
see Donald Glover do you see yourself
like I want to be in that Lane oh yeah
yeah do this you know but I love it I
think that's a magical Lane you know I
mean and he's done comedy this you know
it's it's an amazing thing you know it's
hard for me to monetize all these things
that I do and get that machine behind it
mmm-hmm you know what I mean so it's
just like very indie like I've got the
music with my boy and we just do it for
fun and and this happens like I shot it
to him because it's like so much of mine
is like acting that's where I get my
money yeah I get my money from acting
and everything else I do for fun and
like I'd love for it to be bigger and
bolder and all this but you know I'm
just kind of doing what it is and you
hopefully find success well since
timeless and preacher and all that stuff
and now our house hopefully that gets
picked up knock on wood like you you do
you feel more comfortable about where
you can go with your with your theater
company yeah I mean it's it's
interesting it doesn't it doesn't
translate one-to-one necessarily like
it's interesting like we still have to
build this brand it's like I don't you
say it you know I mean it's like it's
podcast I don't you're saying yeah you
know what I mean it's like you have this
huge following here and then you're like
if you can get like 10% of those people
to come here you know what I mean like
I'm sure there's on any given day you
have a lot more people that are like
seeing you do stand-up and paying to see
you do stand-up to necessarily listen to
your podcast today you know that's gonna
change now that I'm on it it's gonna be
huge
I'm getting the bougie crowds yeah booze
is coming
huge bougie crowds is coming up people
that know math I really think I may just
say more like you know when cuz when
you're struggling as an actor and a
performer especially in this expensive
vast city of La you know it's like you
know you don't necessarily have time to
be like hey let me go do this free
things yeah yeah you you you have to
care and I care greatly about this
because it's probably my biggest outlet
to do the thing that isn't just
completely selfish other than writing
and starting in a play I did this for
you for the art yeah well laughs when I
went to that was a weird one
the tragedy yeah yeah that was weird
yeah you're out there so that's what I'm
saying when I see like you know cuz you
know how Atlanta that shows yeah yeah
it's not like a through-line Today Show
there's sometimes an episode will be
about something that you like what the
[ __ ] yeah but yeah i'ma see like with
what your writing style instead that's
what you want to be yeah our unofficial
motto is our Brown contingent is strong
our white people be pop and [ __ ] the
fourth wall no because we got a for
those of you know fourth wall is and you
break through and talk to the audience
yes oh you sure do do that do what we do
that a lot in this place this one too we
like go through their talk and mess with
the audience and so I know that's it's
something as an audience member I've
been it can be weird
should you could yeah I get that feeling
of how people must feel when they go to
comedy shows and the comedian's like
[Laughter]
yeah you know but we tried never to do
one where like you feel like you have to
be involved more than you should
why cuz that's always the worst word
yeah yeah do I have to do [ __ ] yeah I
came to these are chair yeah I want to
sit in the chairs you know you're yeah
so we try not to do anything I am sorry
you watching we got off track of like
what you gotta watch I'm heavy
I'm always looking at Netflix in them oh
oh are you a documentary guy you've
definitely got type of smart Oh I'm not
interesting no no least I totally
typecast you you were wrong that was
wrong I have no interest in seeing what
really happened who's to say that that
really happened anyway that's just still
somebody I think glass documentary I saw
was like capturing the Friedman's and I
was good okay so what you're watching on
Netflix um two things I'm watching right
now just got into Barry
oh well that's one AGPL that's on HBO
whatever the hell that is Barry the tick
which is Amazon Prime I think my girl
Jana is on there and I just binge black
summer oh I haven't seen that when you
how is that is it good yeah man I
thought it's gonna be sucky man I
thought I was gonna suck ass I'm not see
how did you see I'm brother Academy yeah
I liked it I liked it a lot yeah I do
I like the Umbrella Academy black summer
is good because it's everything you want
for Walking Dead to be oh that's what
it's disarmed be what's a zombie show
but like did you check out a Walking
Dead I still I still watch okay I still
watch I thought this season is really
good I mean about five seasons of it are
repetitive it's like it's like well this
is our new place
oh dammit they're gonna destroy our new
play yeah looks like we need to leave we
found a new place and then they kill all
that then they may kill off someone then
they replace it with someone similar
yeah yeah if a black guy dies on Walking
Dead there's a new place trust me a
black guy gonna be found in the shack
here's our new black guy the only black
guy was annoyed that was their first one
which was a t-bone or whatever they gave
them they gave him so such a ridiculous
name I don't know but I think his real
name was like T bonus like a1 first name
of carrots bone whatever the actor's
name is he had he had one first name and
I was like that is bold of you have one
first name and no music career this is
amazing sir yeah I guys kind of dumped I
always thought that the the zombie kill
to
maduk [ __ ] ratio yes on on walking
dead
it was teetering a lot of times where I
was like I need more like you know that
the season that like was that season
with it at the farmhouse the foot day
was searching for the little white girl
it was just I was like okay this is but
I gotta say though on that final episode
when that little girl walked out of that
barn as a zombie I was in my place I was
I went like this I was like so like I
can't yeah I was like oh maybe that's
what I did it yeah yeah maybe they built
up to that yeah yeah but so you seen
black summer like someone cuts out all
that metal stuff okay it's just like it
just scared you seriously you know I
mean you're just scared and I got to
watch it and they take it from the
perspective of each person there's one I
don't want to spoil it for you but
there's one where they do it from the
perspective of the zombie oh really yeah
but yeah so that that that's my foot
those are my three right now those are
and see those are the types of things
that I would like tick berry black black
summer they all have a sort of gallows
humor to them do you know what I mean
and so that's the sort of content I did
I liked absurdist I like dangerous and
so it's been really interesting no
guilty pleasures I was known Riverdale
for a hot minute binging on nails like
oh it's so funny that you're talking
about the CW because all of my guilty
pleasures are on the seed oh I'm across
to see that well I'm a comic book guy
okay okay so I love Supergirl yeah
Supergirl is the only one I haven't
checked out are you you you know why you
got a watch Supergirl why because they
get it's they have it's actually great
performances on there yeah they're
actually you actually deal with things
like in and how they the character
building is really great on Supergirl I
think you'd like that no I I would I
watched when it was on CBS the only
reason I'm just not caught up on
probably the last year of shows that are
that serial in nature right just from
working I just haven't had a chance cuz
like you know cuz I think I was in
Canada and that's not but like those
shows are like or for me I'm like I have
to watch in order from this to that I
was Vampire Diaries well yeah that was
my [ __ ] and then then they had to
spin-off originals that was my [ __ ] and
now they spun it off again this show
called legacy which is legacies yeah
it's like they're the kids at this
school the salvatore school but i still
I know the lore of that world I know the
rules of that vampire world so I just
enjoy what you know so that's my guilt I
love stuff like that just like science
fiction horror vampire I love all that
kind of stuff because not everything has
to be so deep and heavy all the time
that you watch I don't I don't watch
dramas I don't really be watching dramas
like that like even the drama is that
I'm telling you about
when you look at them they're all like
sci-fi drama like Legion and Westworld
right right right right
Barry's got it and even Wes well you got
lost cuz it's too much drunk like I
don't I don't my life is serious enough
yeah that I don't I don't need a whole
lot of the world's crazy you know what I
mean I don't I don't need things like
I'm I'm personally against I don't need
too much realism in my television and
the thing is it's hard for me to say
that as an actor somebody's trying to be
on TV because like I'm not gonna
necessarily be the lead of anything cuz
I don't got a lead fake not yet you know
what I mean but it's gonna be if I am
it's still gonna be a quirky funny type
thing that's gonna be Eric Griffin right
but what I'm saying is like you know
when I'm looking at like CSI you know
it's like I don't need to see you people
that I can go see it to post office you
know that's real life mm-hmm you know
some popular opinion I guess you know
cuz but I just feel like right now we're
going to this thing where like you're
seeing a lot of like it's like I don't
need to see like fat people and all this
guy you don't need to put them I don't
need to see it I just feel like fat
white women of the new diversity so I'm
like I'm fine like everybody deserved
but I had a certain sort of point you go
is don't we trying to escape this is
escapism right you know it's like when
you like it's like when they start to go
like especially with you transgender
like they want that the actor needs to
be transgender that's the thing that
they're saying and I'm like yeah but
like if the person is accountable in the
show does that person need to be a
cannibal to how far they're gonna go
with it is you know it's interesting
because I don't know how much we've
talked about this and it feels it feels
very case-by-case like I you know what
you totally agree you know what I mean
like there's a there's a there's an
interesting movement happening that that
I find fascinating because it is that
thing this is like Jeffrey Tambor was
like the cutoff apparently for like and
he didn't help his case by being like
inappropriate way ya know like that was
like the cutoff where they were like
okay this is the last time we want
someone and a popular thing who is in
trans playing trend it was like him and
Jared Leto right or and you got Louie
Anderson though but no but see his is
not he's not playing trans he's actually
playing but a mom here's the thing
though little inside story I was like
you know I was on I'm dying up here you
know and we're sitting here talking
about Louie [ __ ] which was a big deal
for you congratulate I know thank you so
I canceled so yeah so we're like I
remember we're sitting around a said and
we're talking about Louie and then
Melissa Leo was a oscar-winning
fantastic actress you know I learned I
learned so much from her but she very
much was like oh yet another part taken
away from oh you know a woman of age mmm
given to a man yeah I totally get that
that's a perspective that I did I was
like oh because like I'm a comic I love
Louie Anderson right and then we're like
he did such a good job wasn't it good
and then in comes a woman you know of
age who's like oh you mean so in other
parts that I yeah oh
no construe cuz I'm up here think about
my black [ __ ] you know wha we got more
black people over here so you know when
you hear Melissa Lee let go like you
know why why isn't that an older white
woman yeah so that's sort of like I know
what you saying by case by case cuz it
was like that that show shrill is on
Hulu but that chick is like absolutely
hilarious what's the name from SNL yeah
yeah is that Edie Bryant I forgot her
name okay oh god we're terrible we don't
need to but she's great but I say so
when you say case by case you know I
just wish you was merit-based where it's
like you were super talented and that's
why you got this I think it's 5050 I
think there's some things that go into
it but these are all factors remember
it's an image business too though so I
never like like if somebody who I see
and they're like you know those handsome
hunky comics you know I'm mad because
this is what comedy supposed to look
like then when they get in there we'll
do but I go I get it too cuz it's an
image business so sad but I feel we're
going on this like weird like right now
we're in a weird times right now were
they're like no we need to get real
people on TV yeah but it's still this is
why I'm for it because at the same time
a lot of it's still tokenism you know
what I mean it's still there's not like
five shows with fat white women right
you know what I means there's to like
you can you can name them do you know
what I mean it's like when you're right
when fresh off the boat came and which
is [ __ ] hilarious to Kate and I'm
friends with a Constance and Randall
we're not friends what we know each
other I know Randall fish a doctor and
oh by the way just real quick side note
about this
I just happen it's all in Hulu so you
know when you're watching Hulu and it
may if you don't click it'll just play
yeah
fresh off the boat just came on and I
was watching a pilot and I was on my
couch Don yeah I couldn't find a remote
and I just feel lazy but I started I
started watching and now I love that
show yes so funny but anyways go on but
remember when that came out dr. Kim was
on air at the same time and I remember
remember I think it was variety or
something like that where they were like
are we going too far with ethnicity or
something like that and I was like to
show it's too homey yeah I was like you
take off one show you've cut off 50% of
network Asian television LED shows you
know and in what happened dr. kid gets
canceled now there's one Asian lead show
on national television I know but this
is what I'm saying about like so the
female movement mm-hmm you know so like
I've got two discussions with some of
these female comics and you know they're
like you know all the lineups are what
no male they're always talking about
male so now it's like all the males are
being lumped in to one box you know it's
like it's so it's like male versus
female and it's like yo take another
look it's still very why we all had to
we had to get our way so let's not take
away from people's struggle but like
where does it end because it's like
every group can be like hey we're not
being represented either so at what
point does it become about talent versus
like this you know yes I mean it's both
right but like she's hard I think I
think you can objectively say that white
people are over represented in
television it's so funny when my like
white friends would be like complaining
about like oh yeah they're not hard why
guys no no it's just no added sugar yeah
yeah yeah yeah no I already got sugar
yeah yeah it's always we it's always
weird hearing that like you know I've
had a friend say that to me to where
they were like do like yeah but I went
in and you know they got a they got a
black guy you know they went with a
black guy instead of a white guy for the
role and I was like okay how often does
that happen in your career and was
everyone else on that show white
everyone else on the show is right yeah
I know so it's not like you're like
white chocolate
I didn't get that part yeah sorry I
don't have any I just don't have any
sympathy yeah there's like no but you
will get to audition for the lead of
something else
it's hard for me to have sympathy you
know for even for even for women it's
hard for me to have sympathy in terms of
in this business that's because of your
sexist wrong let's go get cut ass cut
out it's like you know but I'm just I
mean only because you know it's like I
have more I have because even with
females it needs to be broken down
because I guess I think black women are
on way under represented represented you
know it's so it's like when you hear
white when we're trying to come in talk
about acting like a minority yes it's
it's as weird as I yo it so it's a
little weird but and like to get on your
perspective of like how hard it is it's
like people will get mad at rappers for
doing this you know rappers being here
and I'm like might be I'm coming against
everybody
I don't care if it's a rapper I don't
care if it's if it's a rapper who you
think has no talent or an actor who's
been doing it for a while who has no
talent or some more or some really
attractive actor it's all you against a
bevy of individuals and we're all trying
to get roles but yeah just hate it like
yet we were pitted against each other by
the group that's trying to come in it's
like whatever that group is they're like
hey there's none of us yeah you all are
part of the same thing yeah you know cuz
you're non as if to say it's like Asian
it'd be like it's you either agent or
non-asian yeah I think I don't know as a
man I feel like you got to take that on
the chin man like we're doing much
better than them I know I don't you know
I mean I even black men are getting
represented in ways that I haven't seen
in a long time on television like I
think we're coming up more prominently
than then say black women women are the
least represented this is tough you know
yeah I know but I say I know so now
we're like so now in a pecking order
it's like white women and black men or
right are they at the equal footing now
that what's happening yeah it's it's
weird it's like you can't the
comparisons are we it's weird because
you don't want to compare but at the
same time like reality is reality right
and so like there's an acknowledgment of
a need in certain places so it's a weird
it's is there a need though or is it
just like I
would like to thin my universe I'd like
to think that the need is talent you
would think so you know I I would say
that that's one of those to me all
things being equal statements but things
ain't all things I agree it's like I
just it's just like I feel I feel like
that and I as I'm feeling like it I feel
like man maybe I'm maybe this isn't
right to feel this way but it's it's
just kind of how like we both had that
like aha moment about Louie Anderson you
know say we're here's a here's a woman
of age who's like hey I don't like that
you like ah yeah yeah man we had these
weird like you know like the Game of
Thrones man I'm talking about this on
stage now cause it's like I was looking
at Twitter when remember we saw Arya is
now yeah but she looks she still looks
11 yes so like four men we're like oh my
god she looks but here's the thing
though so I heard like a guy he's
talking about like oh that's is probably
one of the most disturbing things in
Game of Thrones and I'm like yo I
thought oh man what a stupid male
perspective because I do was [ __ ] his
sister and through a little boy off a
balcony half the male cast doesn't have
a dick rape torture and pillaging
throughout the show so this self-made
woman made herself an assassin a
survivor and she wants to decide who
when and where she wants to [ __ ] and we
have a problem with that yeah you got a
revaluate you got revenge you got a
reevaluate somewhere as we're talking
about this I feel like I'm trying I'm
trying to it's like we're always
learning and teetering no and you know
what my problem wasn't even that my
problem was like when she was getting
naked I was like I don't know how I know
I was like well my first thought well
they took me out of the scene because I
was like well she's got to be 18 because
I'm seeing her titties and her booty or
did somebody make a mistake is this
gonna be a birther situation where we
get did the birth certificate I was so
worried about watch and the minute I saw
like butt or whatever and I think I was
with a female who was like excited about
this and I was sitting there like so
excited I was like I don't this is not
one of those things where I want to
present the ID after
words like where she said she was 18 I
was like no I'm not looking and you
could tell me lady but I check it out
even in that world or wouldn't matter no
well so I think in real life she's like
22 I know but what I'm saying though is
in the game of thrones world no they
don't gotta be 18 no no and also bloody
Allah hanging by laws thinthread here
she's like well in Mississippi the
problem though is that like I said it's
with this particular actress her growth
she just looks like a miniature of the
same chick that was 11 yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and you've also watched her
since she was 11 so like that's changed
like Sansa changed like Sansa became a
like she's a voluptuous woman now well
also I hear that the chick who plays
whatever like ties down her breasts
who's going down the young oh that is
the Aria chick yeah yeah okay I think
they Tate I think they want her to look
like a little boy yeah a little more
boyish I know but it's like what a
badass though like turns out to be like
one of one of the most dynamic badass
characters in this series it's great
like I was such a fate like she's jumped
ahead of like somebody for me
I thought she I mean that arc was just
amazing I thought that episode was just
so much happening I thought okay there
was a lot happening this is a good game
of Thrones moment everybody got this
game but so hold on I have to pee like a
[ __ ] yes happy brick oh we can
stop right here right here all right and
we're back from our pee break but I want
to finish off a little game of Thrones
talk let's just talk about the let's
talk about yeah yeah yeah cuz I love
Game of Thrones are you a big fan of it
anytime you have somebody let's talk
about this what's happening right now
you know the first three episodes of
Game of Thrones I thought this was just
fantastic television I thought it was
great you know I feel like other writers
mentioned I think it was I don't know if
it was the first or second episode right
before the battle yeah it's probably
this last one where hunger lost her
virginity I assume that was episode two
yes I thought they just did a great job
of reuniting every character but that's
from Anna
really organic way that's an almost
impossible feat you know to have each
one of them have their own story and and
check in they have basically have the
audience check in with all of the
characters because we've been watching
them for seven years yeah and then we
also know I go oh they haven't seen each
other and so yes yeah it was like in
some of the writing in the lines like
one of the best lines for me like that
really represents who Aria has become as
when Jon Snow says me how'd you sneak up
on him and he was really like and I was
like and in my mind I wanted to be like
boy yeah you'd be dead yeah and if she
kills the night king at the same spot oh
that's right yeah very very over yeah
yeah somebody pointed out like the same
part where she sneaked up one was the
same point where she she kills the night
king oh that's probably why they set it
up like that
okay so I thought like I said episode 1
I thought was a great like
reintroduction I thought it was also
like seeing the growth of all the
characters like because I could like the
women in this show it's just it's crazy
but the most important moment to me in
episode 1 was when two moments was when
when Danny goes to tell Sam hey I killed
your father and brother okay now the
reason to me it was significant is
because this is the first time we're
questioning her like we're like oh maybe
oh she might need to go to that wasn't a
good choice because Sam is the heart and
soul of the show he's the heart and soul
he's like you know the moral compass is
Jon Jon's the moral compass but Sam is
like they're like you know we love him
and I felt that's the first time I think
oh I don't think she should have killed
right my favorite part is him going
she's like I killed your father well you
know never really liked him
I have a brother though that's the good
thing always good to have family
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know that's why he was like okay you
know what I don't know some [ __ ] about
this girl anyway you know what you ain't
even one [ __ ] queen without but that's
why I like seeing brands so brand coming
into picture and brand is like hey um
yeah can y'all stop fighting there's a
[ __ ] frozen dragon coming so y'all
need to like get over this [ __ ] and
then you go tell John he's really the
king ya know how many people are named
brand on this show I feel like there's
four bronze oh there's a bran right I
don't know there's a couple brah I feel
like they were but I just think that
here's another thing in the first
episode that I noticed how how strong
and significant of how how grand these
characters have become because up to
this point
Daenerys Dany has been like like a
larger-than-life character but when I
saw her next to Sansa and all these
people I was like oh because even though
actress herself as small as natural but
like cuz I think the girl that plays
Songza like she is so like like I want
her to be my queen you know I'm gonna
see you know to me she got that and I
think she they're making Dany smaller
they're making her character not as
important well you know what's
interesting is I for a bunch of
characters who have been on opposite
ends of the earth yeah for a lot of it
they fit into each other's world really
easily
now you're talking as an actor right now
though no no I think as a I'm a maybe
that's him but no cuz I get you that's
the amazing part about it to me too like
they have nest not necessarily work
together in seven years
you know they've worked on this project
but like even even not as an actor cuz
watching like watching say like a
Justice League or something like that
where you're watching a bunch of
different characters suddenly coming to
each other it just doesn't work and you
go like whose movie is this what is
their world how do they fit in or even
like I'm a comic book guy right so an
example is when they did Batman and
Robin and brought in Batgirl and all of
a sudden Robin doesn't know how to do
anything because they have to build
Batgirl and Alicia Silverstone as a
character oh so all of a sudden he
doesn't know how to do stuff he all of a
sudden on a safe things
and so what's great about Game of
Thrones another fantastical world is
that you have these people who
interacting and it makes complete sense
what they're doing
no one suddenly has to change there's no
character assassination because we're in
a room with another person and now we
have to figure out how to make this work
yeah I uh yes I know exactly what you're
saying like they come in and everything
makes sense
it makes sense the intentions and it's
all the tension is so great because you
you're building up to this like yeah oh
man they haven't seen each other and I
know all this that's exactly how I
should play out yes exactly I should
play out episode 2 was great when she
was like I don't
Minna Dom when a day they do dumb things
for women like she very much has
contempt for Jon's choices even though
she also respects him and wants him to
lead like all the women of that you know
who's a bad [ __ ] on that show is that
lady more want oh oh the little girl I
was so I've cried I've quite every
episode I've cried on watching Game of
Thrones because that little girl is
she's such a great actress cuz she's
inspiring like the way she delivers the
line I was inspired by her she says wow
isn't spot like there's a way where that
seems really contrived mm-hmm and it
didn't from me I believe every word that
comes out of her mouth yeah because when
she stood up and was like you know in I
think it's the first episode of the
season when she's like yo man who's this
[ __ ]
no but she's very much like yo we
elected you King and now you coming in
town with this chick yeah explain
yourself yeah you know and John as I
said the moral compass has to be like
guys we we'd be dead yeah [ __ ] got
dragons dude dragons
yeah so it's like and I don't want to be
king just like okay so we had this
moment now another significant moment in
episode 1 from Sam is when he says to
him and this is what the whole [ __ ]
series is gonna be about the final
deputies anism hey you gave up being
king gave up for the good of the people
she you that ooh and that was a moment I
was like oh okay yeah that's doubt so
and then of course another like weird
moment in the first episode wasn't when
you know she's like if you want to [ __ ]
go buy one but if you want to Queen
earned her two minutes later my boy my
boy slick yeah well your did my boy I
like that dude that's my favorite favor
do evil character that's my favorite new
do
cuz he's just outfit his stuff smash
like look I want to beg Queen yeah baby
really don't care about my family to be
yeah I got my lease tied up in a rocket
ship yeah so okay so that was and then I
love Theon story good for Fiona just to
hold the whole idea that like you could
be so horrible and redeem you like look
how many people have redeemed themselves
like I said Jaime Lannister's through a
kid out of window people people
controversy book the Jaime Lannister
part is controversial man cuz it's just
like did he redeem himself I know he's
he's gonna die yeah yeah they're all
gonna die like no one's it the ones that
have done [ __ ] up [ __ ] even if they've
redeemed myself they're gonna die with
honor I love what they did with Brienne
oh I'm so true I will tell you this I
was balling hottie knighted her I've
been I've been in I've been in a cold
world of not caring about nobody yeah
day night at Brienne it was like you
know what they had another scene like
this in last season it's when she gave
Tyrion the hand of the king yeah yeah
it's the same moment it's the same one
because like everything he's gone
through and everything's done this is
now he is now you know small in stature
but he's got the biggest brain in the
room and he earned it and that's the
first time he felt like it I was crying
for that but but when Jamie night at her
man I was like this is so perfect and I
have Jamie do it yeah do you know what I
mean yeah like that I just fell and it
was so real which she's like you know I
don't even want to be a knight I don't
like well you just need me tonight you
and she's like well I mean if you're
here sure whatever
no take it just one knee
I just thought it was just such a moving
beautiful moment and it represents like
like I said the women of this show as
I'm looking at it through a different
prism after like just you know it's like
this show it's not kind to women because
Emily what's-her-face herself was like
yeah I'm not gonna be naked anymore so
yeah you're not seeing these titties
anymore so even a real world real world
ramifications ramifications where she's
like I'm not gonna do that and that's
what I thought was so great about what
they did with Arie it was like it wasn't
good - it is no I thought you know it
felt like she had agency all the women I
know we're huge fans of that moment yeah
I was but they're huge fit all the guys
were he's funny that I want I talked
about this on stage and women start
clapping and I'm like oh this is really
is like a total female perspective of
like she chose when where and who yeah
she was she wasn't forced she was this
was her choice and it's like okay I get
it you know what you think of Avengers 2
Avengers this is gonna be literally the
longest podcast I've ever done and I
love it because you could always say
keep going we gonna keep going alright
Game of Thrones game throw this was also
the this is probably the happiest you'll
see the characters and the audience for
Game of Thrones because they like to cut
your heart out okay yeah yeah and no cuz
people gonna die these first two
episodes were amazing because they
didn't rely on what they've kind of been
known for doing which is just like
surprise you with a gut wrenching death
yeah they actually surprised us by
making just a fun well-written episode
where all the characters have something
positive happened to them which has not
been with anyone for episode - yeah so -
in preparation for this light yeah that
was just them going let's have some good
feelings because the storm is coming
yeah and I thought the winter is finally
here and I thought it was I thought it
was great because there's a lot of shows
that they lose the tension by doing that
because because they're trying to pace
you for this next thing where action
happens they lose the tension in the
episode before yeah and I never felt
bored by that I never I never went there
like where's the sword fighting why
isn't someone [ __ ] or getting killed
yeah I just sat there and watched the
story unfold but they have a lot of
moments like that like how many times
have there been like 10 12 minute like
Tyrion you know the the he's always he's
always has great like discussions with
people and they go a long time and it's
perfect for the thing so I know what
you're saying they prepare for this big
battle I mean I guess that cried when
Sansa and Greyjoy hugged I was so
touched because it's like he cuz I feel
for him yeah he lost his dick he's been
tortured he was a coward he one of the
stark kids are dead because of him and
he's like I gotta make this right
and then when they like so in episode 3
and when bran says hey you're a good man
yo that was the moment we said you were
good man that's where he's gonna die
yeah as if to say that's all he needed -
yeah
thank you your guy that was him saying I
forgive you for what you've done
you know and then I the only thing about
this is I want to know why the night
king wanted bran so bad they don't
explain it to me or maybe they haven't I
missed it I feel like so I I miss out on
minutia like this yeah and just go like
I generally get it like because he's
like he's magic or some peas the magic
prophecy boy right yeah you know what I
mean he's like he's like matrix it's
like the majors with me when he wanted
to get the the Oracle see he wants to
get the Oracle to be a part of this yeah
the collective it's like yeah I look at
it like he's the golden child yeah yeah
[Music]
only thing I'll say my only negative
about episode 3 was like this battle
with all these dead coming these
[ __ ] should be dead Oh
like every time like the camera would
pan to like Brienne she died right there
and then they cut to she's still alive
yeah like when she cuz the first one
they did a good job of this cuz when she
first gets attacked you think she's dead
yeah that first one was she's like yeah
yeah my god she do cuz I also don't know
the full powers of these
yes they become zombies or is it the
nightcap mr. Rais yeah when do they bite
people yeah I don't know what it was
stabbing my first Avenue I also wasn't
sure the consistency of like how these
things died because sometimes they'd
exploded in a dust
uh-huh and I feel like sometimes they
just fall down oh well it was the glass
the glass yeah they all everybody had
glass weapons but do they all or or that
love Valyrian steel yeah yeah but does
the do they do they all do they
sometimes dire they they always just
explode in a duck I think it just
depends on what they're being killed
with right see that's inconsistent
that's not that's like come on yeah okay
I don't hey hey hey I don't care I was
just curious like I don't know what tree
Aria popped out of when she jump yeah
I'm all right
that was badass and I heard she was
badass like which is killing them all in
the bath then the Hound came to save her
then that guy died everybody that died I
was like oh this is yes is fantastic no
I had that moment to where it was like
where all of a sudden there's like all
the all the like an army of 100 I'm dead
surrounded Jon Snow I was like oh this
is how he dies yeah and it is like a
cutaway and him he's fighting I was like
no I thought he was gonna I thought it
would have been great if he would have
fell off the dragon in Episode one and
that's how Jon Snow doctor that would
have been such a twist twist like that
okay
so anyway first three episodes great and
I did feel like this big battle that
they've been raging for I did feel like
it went kind of quick in the season cuz
now it's like okay so the real enemy is
gonna be Circe's you know yeah I mean
she needs to die horribly it's the
longest recorded battle scene I think in
history with it and actually you can't
even rewatch it like they won't even
like when you go back to HBO go I
believe it's a shortened version no I
think so I think it was only for that
night that they had to because it was an
hour 26 hour and change it was a hour
and change like this podcast is like
this podcast is the third episode of
Game
that's 33.5 yeah the podcast was leading
up to this stabby
I know but that was great was she killed
I was like I didn't know what was great
about it I didn't expect it
no I didn't expect it at all I just
thought while bran is about to get got
cuz that's what happens in this show
yeah and he's just sitting there like I
after he knew I think he's like okay
knew everything and it was just great
she dropped the knife stabbed him she
saved everybody and it's like and now it
becomes like wow she's she should I
don't know what it means for Arya now
you know to me but it's so great yeah I
mean here's the thing no on this show
warriors don't become kings or queens
yeah yeah yeah they don't become Lee no
they don't become Lee they don't become
leaders ever yeah anyway it's just such
a great like when you look if you're
looking for a strong jonno character you
know but again another great moment is
him going there Danny and being like
yeah I'm kind of first of all so I mean
fu and that was like a great moment for
her because that thing that's the first
time she's doubted her whole existence I
think well up to this point you know
what's funny is it puts such a rift
between cuz to me it didn't even felt
like she she I think she believes she's
not she doesn't even it doesn't want to
believe it because here's it's the most
honorable man she's ever met in her life
I think there might be yeah there might
be a part of her believes but I think
she's just not she's not here is a shame
[ __ ] with that truth at all she she's
gonna make a choice yeah so yeah well I
did this but I deserve this yeah she's
like you know I don't just cuz you were
born in a [ __ ] tower someplace but
she I earned this but she also doesn't
even really believe it because she was
like no no I'm telling you you
leave it that's what makes it it's not
that she's gonna wake up one day be like
yeah you right you came no no no I think
no he deserves it but she's like I
earned yes but I think it's the part the
part that doesn't believe is just like I
think there's no part that's gonna
accept right right right right right
do you know what I mean that's where it
well said you know I think she's just
like oh who told you this your boy oh
yeah yeah yeah who are the one whose
parents I killed yeah exactly
how'd I do okay so I killed his daddy
and his brother not the king okay I
think but I think she said that
half-heartedly because she was reaching
for an excuse I think yeah I mean yeah
that's John's conviction is just it's
you know and he was avoiding her I mean
he's such aa man I just I don't I'm
gonna really be sad when that when he
dies I might come on if he dies I might
have let it pop off one more time all
right so that's candy Thrones
we both love Game of Thrones I'm
actually gonna have Malcolm come back
again at the end of the season and we'll
talk some more but since we're on this
subject of talking about things and
you're a nerd you got Batman shirt on I
almost wore my Batman I think Avengers
end game how you feeling I'm gonna give
you a hot take you have a hot take on it
I think that the movie went great until
they made a black Captain America lost
American no let me start by saying I was
not a fan of infinity war when I first
saw it when I went to the feet and I saw
it I was like and that's why I wasn't
surprised that Black Panther would did
better in box office gross because I
just was like but after watching it over
and over on planes and on Netflix I just
really fell in love with it you know
yeah go ahead
you also don't like Black Panther right
Oh Ben thank you that was terrible that
is one of that is terrible I'm just
trying to point out to you this okay
let's just be real okay if it was called
white Panter with the exact same story
and everything we wouldn't it would just
be like that was a it was a pedestrian
movie in the MCU universe it wasn't it's
not even for me in the top 5 of the MCU
movies oh I actually think it's a really
amazing movie I actually am really
excited honestly this is why please tell
me why I'm so glad we're talking about
this yeah please please we would start
let me just give you some some things so
you know you go alright in civil war
mm-hmm the character Black Panther was a
much stronger with passion and and and
Drive and I believed what he was doing
he was trying to avenge his father he
was kingly and then he redeemed himself
in the end being like oh I can't do this
revenge this week at person in the Black
Panther movie who's he suckin on his
mama's tit and might not believe in he's
like yo mom what should I do sister what
should I do
like that's that's a sign of what's
going on in society where we have to be
like let's force strong female
characters on instead of it being
organic this is what I'll say I do I
actually do here I haven't heard that
perspective and I do hear you with that
I thought he was much more streamlined
in the civil war civil war sure better
character better character development
in like much more believable character
head in the movie I think more
streamlined but I would say that's not a
call to society that's a call that of
comics in terms of the strong female
maternal sense of who he's relying on so
I think you have to in order to broaden
that world you need to see that I just
thought they did a really excellent job
of creating a world creating spectacle
and that universe for me I know I know
for you but for me I had never seen that
world that that sort of spectacle and
these characters I really was amazed by
it what I was let down by by and it's a
movie I loved was the final fight scene
only because they did this they fell
into the same trap that all the movies
do where the enemy is the exact same
person as the hero do you not I mean
like the first Iron Man movie the
and like ant-man the inner enemies and
yeah the what like they just keep
falling into these tropes of just like
they're luring oh that guy was the most
interesting character in the movie and I
wanted to hear more about his story he I
think he is probably one of the best MCU
villains
aside from Thanos then why do all the
black actors in the movie have to do the
Denzel Washington glory cry with the one
single the one single tear got to come
down the cheek right here can I I'm a
man that's how black people cry
I like this that's how black people cry
oh God you got too many other races in
you that's why they cry let me pick
apart Black Panther for you know I've
seen I've seen your stand a bit so I
know I don't talk about this stuff right
okay it doesn't make like this why would
there only be one Black Panther why why
why why they got just they got this
flower get the [ __ ] out of here they got
all this technology what why would they
be spreading that around there should be
an army of them because it's also a
royal it's a it's a royal blessing yeah
that's what is not there technologically
advanced culture they they're not
they're not believing in like that kind
of non say yeah
second thing this nanotechnology it's
too unbelievable
it's too that's that's across the MCU oh
yeah yeah
but once they added that it's a it's too
unbelievable like the thing that made
Iron Man great was the fact that you saw
the process so even if it's something
far-fetched I believe that he could have
got there in the movie this [ __ ] with
the you know this just coming out of
sure he's a [ __ ] genius sure is
creating all this [ __ ] also here you
give an Iron Man a lot of credits
because every time you see him he had a
brand new nanotechnology that no one
explained at all where they saw but that
was because after they saw them this is
all after black panther
I feel like two three no still no no no
there was this mall after I have to
check out because bleep Andrew said they
said we're gonna give our junk we got
you so I just didn't I believed that
Thor is a God that's more believable
than that nanotechnology [ __ ] one more
thing you want to go but one more thing
the guy that the ball head girl from
walking dead yeah her husband yeah yeah
he turned on them too easy
yes why would he he's below this whole
time this one [ __ ] comes into
town but he would if that guy had that
kind of character he already would have
known would already stole the purple
[ __ ] and became black 100% agree so
that's in this middle but by the way a
lot of holes in that movie that's my
whole point why are they fighting up on
a [ __ ] hillside in every move those
didn't Bob I don't like black holes
[Laughter]
why no white lies yes here's why I
didn't like in-game okay and I haven't
said this out loud that's do it actually
I liked in-game I liked that movie I was
not emotionally invested Oh cried it to
you everybody I know all the male
friends of mine who were fans of movie
cried at the end yeah - wheezes
superhero movies when somebody we love
dies and any time like a autistic kid
shoots three-pointers at a basketball
game you know those deaths that gets us
I don't know if my brand is allowed to
laugh at that
shoes reporters in a basketball game man
I'm out Magra falls a bit like of an
autistic Captain America died before
shooting a three-pointer that's the
that's where you're crying I just I
would be heart it would be heart
wrenching you know ok so here's so let's
hear it so how come buried right here
you hear here first does not like end
game that's ago in game is trash there's
not a parent
so in games an amazing movie it wasn't
made right infinity Wars I love much
better really by far by far and this is
this is probably why and this is
probably it's because of inside stuff
once it became they lost me during a
time travel they lost me was thinking
like because your show got canceled and
you were like yeah I was like this
doesn't make any sense this should be
one black guy complaining about we
didn't like the time travel I was
bothered by the time travel why for the
exact reasons that they pointed out
which was there they go no time travel
can't work like that but it worked like
this and back to the future and then
they name 28 movies huh where this is
how it should work and then the reason
why it doesn't work in every logical way
that you think is just like I thought
that they I thought that their
explanation of how they were wrapping
this up made sense to me
III enjoyed how they did it couldn't did
not like it and and I just like and I
just took right you know suspension of
disbelief thing travel always has that
problem because in my cuz it was my way
my brain works I was thinking like so
now Thor Thor in that universe he don't
got his hammer his hammers just gone you
don't I mean like so like so that whole
universe stream is gonna be completely
different because he don't have his
hammer you know in that in Thor 2 I
could I couldn't rationalize it yeah so
I couldn't rationalize the changes that
they were making to the past
no no but check this out we check this
out the bald-headed witch lady explained
it I love the dust with the ancient one
you the ancient
tilda swinton yeah the witch lady
because she explained it like there are
now alternate universes this is a
multiverse so like for instance Loki his
show this coming out that's how they set
it up ya know it's him with the
tesseract in his thing so there's
multiple universes they're trying to
save their universe I know I know I
didn't feel that
okay guys didn't that did but any time
travels tricky so Tantra and look you're
talking to want someone who's been on a
time-travel show who's seen a bunch of
time-traveling [ __ ] like I grew up on
time-travel [ __ ] I just felt like they
yada yada it okay it just felt like I
thought they did a good job you know
what we difference yeah it's like when
they say when someone
you know how a movie will point out
something is doing they let you know you
know what I mean it was just like so
what we only have one woman or like that
do oh I know I know you're like oh so
this is to make us not but that's why I
didn't like Infinity Ward when I first
watched it some moments were like when
the black girl says like why is she
being up here the whole time I was like
yeah why the [ __ ] is Scarlet Witch the
most powerful character on on in
currently
why is she up and then I wanted to see
more not Cherie a koi a because she's
there in the beginning and then I guess
she just stays in Rwanda yeah but she's
gonna be a but she's gonna have her
black panther too but that's why I felt
like that like that felt contrived I was
like oh we just don't well that one
moment in any game to wear was like the
me to moment you know it was like oh
like a wink you know it was a hundred
percent yeah and I didn't mind I didn't
mind
I didn't mind either they could have
done it differently perhaps but there
was some like awesome moments in endgame
okay I'm talking about like a moment and
then when Captain America picked up
Thor's hammer yeah yeah you know I
thought that was just like that just
that was the moment in the movie where
you were like oh my god you know it was
it was really awesome my other problem
is when Captain Marvel at the beginning
of it she's like yeah you probably not
gonna see me for about hour and a half
two hours if I do 100 100 and I'm coming
back with a [ __ ] up here okay
it was so clearly like cuz here's what
really happened right like she went on a
lady golf tour yeah I was like with the
minute she said there's all these
planets that stuff has to happen I was
like oh yeah I was like oh so you're
gonna come back in the last half hour
yeah like never but what was great about
it though but check it out what was
great about it was like I forgot about
her so her entrance her re entrance was
still great yeah I just was like she's
gonna be here unless it just felt like a
written
I know but okay here's a problem I have
with the infinity war
okay so here's Daniels alright Ironman
basically drops a mountain on him gamora
not gomorrah the the robot chick yeah
yeah what's her name that's come on
that's good more she hits him with a
spaceship but the only thing that draws
blood his Iron Man punches him in the
face oh yeah for sure that was that's
the kind of [ __ ] where I go what yeah no
but think about when you bring comics
into like the cinematic world the power
consistency yeah a little it gets a
little weakest a little weird it gets a
little weird where you like cuz even
when they beat him easily and I thought
they did a good job cuz they beat him
pretty easily when they see him at the
beginning of the movie oh but he was
weak exactly he was hurt yeah I thought
they did his job because it was like oh
he's hurt he's got no stones they
whooped his ass yeah you know what I
mean but if it is that thing of like so
what draws blood how does that so that's
not that kind of [ __ ] like it stays in
my mind like yes I will tell you that I
really thought I leaned over and no
disrespect to Zach Snyder but I leaned
over to a friend of mine about half-hour
and in a movie and I was like these are
scenes you'll never seen a Zack Snyder
movie and I say that because I don't
think I've seen a superhero movie that
was this emotional oh yeah a lot like I
was talking to a friend and we're
Baldwin and I was like you know what
this movies about this movies about
coping like infinity Wars was about loss
and protecting yeah yes yeah shoot like
Civil War was about let's get a bunch of
these [ __ ] we finally got a bunch
of these [ __ ] we gonna fight
like that was a really like more of an
Avengers movie than Civil War two
mountain one of the best most Civil War
to me and is the best Avengers why also
like what do you um there's the first
one and it was with ultra what's the guy
with their arm uh what Bucky Winter
Soldier
yeah Winter Soldier was the best one
yeah you know what I always mix them up
yeah Winter Soldier was great and then
Civil War was great who's
movies better than black panther by the
way who's the first who's the first
enemy in the original Avengers oh that
was the that was there was Santos as you
know what's his name
Thor's brother Loki in the first one
right and if aliens come yeah yeah
Thanos his army
yeah yeah but I think Civil War and and
Winter Soldier are the best Avengers
yeah honestly because it's the first
time you're seeing these real team ups
there's awesome scenes in the and the
event I really love that an end game
that they showed that great Avengers
scene though that really may moved me
when I first saw the Avengers 1 then
when they circle around all the
characters yeah yeah yeah yeah you see
they're all there that was great I love
it I love the Hulk was hilarious in main
game I loved I wanted him to be Hulk
though no I loved I actually love you
love smart hawk I loved it because I
just never thought as a kid I'd see this
many iterations of the whole oh I know
do you know what I mean the fact that we
got classic Hulk then we got you know
can barely talk halt yeah and then we
got brain home yeah whatever he's called
I just thought it was so great and I
just as a the kid in me never thought
I'd see this I I know exactly you're
saying you know it's the first time I
remember the first time you saw the
spider-man the first spider-man yeah but
that was like wow they did it oh can I
tell you I hated the spider the first
one yeah oh I didn't hate it
I only because it was like it was like
oh they they actually did this there was
part of me that loved LT actually did
this but my favorite part of spider-man
is so stupid this is like such an actor
thing my favorite superhero moment is
when because I love practical effects
over everything else
ah I know is like too many weird CGI
things for me but my favorite movies
were he's coming down and talk to Aunt
May and just sort of jumps against the
wall and comes down that was like my
favorite moment it's such a weird thing
but that was unknown to me and also
Tobey Maguire is not who's amazing it I
feel I feel like I'm always gonna run
into these people no he's an amazing
actor he's not spider-man he's not
spider-man's more witty and this kid is
playing it now so much kid is yeah this
kids great and you know what's funny is
this kid is perfect and I liked Andrew
Garfield III actually like he's too emo
for me I like those because he was he
was the witty crack jokes spider-man we
for me the reason Spiderman was my
favorite superhero to iclicker solder
man Khan was because he was a funny nerd
yeah yeah yeah that's why I liked her
that's not what he was in the first
number three we should be if you're
gonna talk about all Marvel Universe
movies that's one of the worst ever it's
horrible what the Sandman is shaking
[ __ ] dammit and they've got no no
disrespect to Topher Grace but he is not
Brock Brock like Eddie Brock he's not
good forgotten him Tom Hardy was a great
venom that was a good movie but that
just it just feels see here's the
problem tell you that movies garbage
that movies garbage but is the greatest
garbage movie because Tom Hardy he's
great [ __ ] amazing this is what I
said - I say hey listen you take Tom
Artie out of that is he that
[ __ ] sells it but my problem
with that movie is the fact that it's so
outside of the universe see the problem
that that Marvel has now is we are now
trained to know that these are all
connected so that's what my problem with
Thor dark world this ship is coming and
I'm like where's Iron Man
well that surprised Captain America
that's the problem with making Avengers
movies ya know with a comic book is that
the minute they're they have their own
stories you're like where's everybody
else but you could do it if it makes
sense
there's no can I tell you some there's
no world where that makes sense there's
no dark world sure but but but endgame
made a lot of reference to dark world
yes but there's no world where once
these guys team up there's ever a thing
happening to earth where only one of
them this thank you it's just this it
can't happen that's just not a so
because I see that Marvel sign and I
know it's Sony's Marvel but I'm like
okay yeah then I'm where spider-man or
worse like this this can't be it's a
weird it's a weird outlier yeah it's a
really weird but Tom Hardy did it's
great he's you know have you seen his
show taboo no oh that's the one you
gonna loved him okay yeah I'm on it it's
an old timey but it's great he was great
on you could use Gators you see pink I
didn't see that one pinky Blount you
should see okay I'm gonna watch that and
you watch hundreds that Tom Hardy did to
venom what Hugh Jackman did to Wolverine
because overact it
now he's kidding laughs of all Marvel
movies I think Logan Logan for me is at
the top thing there never should have
been another Wolverine movie after
Wolverine origin that movie was he
listened atrocious on his own and
destroyed other characters well no but
here's the thing they fixed it they
fixed it
in x-men days of final day they fixed it
they found a way to what it's the same
thing with Star Trek no you're not a way
to wipe away - no that's great start
over I'm talking from not not in terms
of world I'm talking to his like of
money I'm like there's no way another
movie should have been green laughter
that har but this is with so many bad
ones
it's amazing about how great Hugh
Jackman was and a testimony to Ryan
Reynolds - is that they both made the
horrible this horrible movie and America
still said well oh just chuck the whole
movie bring Hugh Jackman back HECO like
you know what I mean like and they made
that second movie which is better than
origins yeah but I wanted it to be
better than it was but like again Hugh
Jackman so good they said [ __ ] it let's
do it
you pulled a trilogy out of a movie
where the the first one is garbage yes I
don't know how that they need to like
I'm hearing now that the universes are
now gonna be combined because they
bought they got the right to own
everything yeah so the hopefully that'll
be here because I'd love to see
Wolverine and you know and [ __ ] it but
now we can't see Iron Man and Wolverine
you know yeah I don't know if you're
gonna see green but also like that's the
thing with x-men like they've just
messed with that world so much like
nobody ruined it nobody can
yeah yeah Fantastic Four like they just
like yeah like any it's like all the
yeah because musics these x-men just
dead Dark Phoenix looks good
are we gonna see it oh you're gonna see
it you're gonna see it don't act like
you're not gonna see it you're gonna see
it what's the last x-men movie that was
it was that was the one before that
we're we're like wasn't days that God
died there was a god guy yeah that was
terrible it was terrible that was
horrible
you don't they got so busy replacing the
character yeah I know that no one's
interesting
I know I don't care about in
these people I don't know who this act I
don't know who they are why don't you I
don't know it's making a sense and I saw
apocalypse or whatever x-men apocalypse
and I just that's another one where the
the power set makes no sense
yeah like x-men apocalypse in the
beginning of it he kills like 11 people
by like putting sand through them yeah
to the next with a gesture yeah and all
of a sudden you're punching people
yeah I don't know what we're doing yeah
I just don't know what this movie I
agree you know what I mean but like that
one was they they owe so much and Lord
Jesus if they destroy storms character
again they have not gotten you won't
talk about who has the worst fight you
like to talk about in derivatives in a
black woman like yeah they have not
written one good line for storm in 15
years 15 years there's not one good
storm line well hopefully this this new
x-men and then whatever it's gonna
happen with the universe I mean I didn't
like I said to get back to it I did
enjoy endgame I thought that I enjoy I
thought I'm glad they started it where
they ended it you know the whole MCU you
know with the iron man dying it was very
moving and all that and I thought the
final fight that final battle was epic
and it was I just I'm gonna see it again
I just yeah I would watch it again and I
just looked and thought wow look at all
the characters that make sense dude now
see this is done that now we're just now
we're talking this people that are in
the business now I'm talking as a
business for like me too because that's
the thing that I thought about like I
said this day of serviced because that's
what I appreciate about infinity war
like I'm like oh they're servicing all
of these characters all of them they're
servicing them and like it all makes
sense it all but you know just great
moments you know the fact that they put
so many different worlds and so many
characters from so many different worlds
together and it makes complete sense is
triumphant because yeah you you see when
it's done wrong it was it was a great 11
years of like in DC is just like DC's
like you're trying too hard that [ __ ]
saw all their [ __ ] sucks it's not all
this sucks
isn't that great my boy Jeff was like
you know why they wrapping it up
why they need to keep going I was like
they aren't gonna keep it's like Jeff I
was like Jeff think about it think about
this you've been watching a series of
movies for over 11 over 11 years and
you're like why are they wrapping it up
yeah this is 11 yeah this is like The
Sopranos it's got to go and like not
even just one arc that you're watching
you're watching five about four or five
different and they're all interconnected
the actors are changing their scrilla
G's like for these people have trilogy
have two and you're going I can't
believe we're wrapping it up yeah this
is the fourth Avengers movie yeah just
Avengers yeah like and each avenger' has
three movie you've watched us yeah
Captain America's got a buncha yes
Sidney's 12 movies that's a testament to
how well they did this yes it was em
it's not over it's not there's about
three or four now I know that light now
I know that the spider-man I'm releasing
these trailers before right now is that
gonna be a prequel to something but now
we know it's after you know after
[Laughter]
wonderful ever oh man uh-huh but yeah
but you knew but see that's why infinity
war the ending I was touched but it
didn't hit me as much because I was like
oh Black Panther 2 is coming out
spider-man homecomings coming out right
everyone's gonna live and that's also oh
I know that's also kind of how I knew
what was gonna happen with the next with
end game because I was like oh they got
a time-travel OC I'm with you see that's
just cuz you're a [ __ ] nerd yeah
we're both nerds because I was in the
theater like cuz it was like that was
all I knew it was just a fake fake out
move that they're gonna get to gauntlet
and snap everybody back I was like that
ain't gonna happen I knew it was gonna
be about because I saw ant-man and the
wah
and I knew in a in a day they set it up
there that's why they set it up because
he was seeing time and all this [ __ ]
about time in that movie was to set it
up for ya game also oh this is the bone
I had to pick about the time-travel part
uh-huh
ant-man comes out and he's like yeah
that was five years for you guys but it
was only like five minutes from me right
then it's the reverse for the remainder
of the movie then I'm like oh yeah when
he's in there well that's that's ten
years under night because Tony Stark
fixed it math doesn't reverse he'll you
go New York you can't suddenly go look
when I was in doing that usually nothing
quantum time took it took me five
minutes but it was five years now all of
a sudden five years in the quantum world
is no no no no but it's it could be
there there in the quantum world it
could be anything no it was only one way
from then on no no that's because they
he they found a way to manipulate it
that's what what Tony Stark was like
there's a lot of [ __ ] moments like
that in uh in like feel specially by
Pantera but we're not gonna go back to
that but like infinity war they all have
holes but I still think it was a
ginormous enough movie and a great
payoff there I'm fine with it
yeah and it's look I'm sure it's because
I'm such a time travel guy that there's
nothing worse than a black nerd they
have to try extra hard to be like you
know black nerds gotta prove this oh
yeah it's real math yeah yeah I'm
suppose you can pull out a sharpie and
be like let me explain yeah no no I went
to math and science eyes well you know
what anyway this is a good stopping
point because it is but this is the
record the longest rhythm with Griffin
we've ever had it's the end game this is
the end game of podcasts today for me at
least and I am gonna have you on again
because I want to continue to talk Game
of Thrones so let's like make an
appointment that for the end of the
season of Game of Thrones we'll talk
about that listen
hope you've enjoyed I hope you stuck
around till this point make sure to look
at the descriptions that I'll have all
of Malcolm's information if you want to
follow him and make sure that what tell
us the name of the comfort to play
company again name of the company is mo
theater comm you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as a mo
theater or ammunition theater munition
theater yeah and it's going on till May
19th this this podcast will come out
before that so you'll have plenty of
time to catch catch to play I highly
recommend it
Malcolm's a fantastic performer like I'm
a fan that's just your friend I'm a fan
that's what I love seeing you on the
shows like I like I really enjoyed that
little bit part in santa clarita diet I
was so excited to see you in that so
he's doing a lot of great things
hopefully our house gets picked up
you know they passed me over but I'm
cool I'm not gonna be hating on the show
no so in any ways man thanks for coming
on yeah I wanted you wanted I got you on
and we did it and thank you guys for
listening to Ripper McGriff and make
sure you hit the subscribe share all
that stuff you supposed to do for me and
tweet out and everything like that and I
hope you enjoyed the show and I'll see
you next week deal [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]